so what i have here is two different
transformation matrices and what we're
going to think about in this video is
can we construct
a new matrix that's based on the
composition of these transformations
or a simpler way of saying that a new
transformation that's based on applying
one of these transformations first and
then the other one
right after that so first let's just
review what's going on
if we have some random vector here
a b we know that we could view this
as a times the one
zero vector the unit vector in the x
direction
plus b times the zero one vector this
what the unit vector that goes in the
vertical direction
now if you were to apply this
transformational capital a here
it tells you instead of using 1 0 and 0
1 use these two columns instead
so if you were apply the transformation
here i guess we could call it
a b prime
that is going to be if you apply capital
a transformation matrix it's going to be
a times not 1 0 you use 0 5
instead and then plus b times not 0 1
you use 2
negative 1 instead so that's just a
little bit of review
but we're going to think about in this
video is what would be the
transformation matrix
for the composition and i could write
that as b
of a right over here
and you might recognize this from
function notation
where essentially it's saying you would
apply the function a first
and then whatever the output of that is
you would then input that into b
and you would get the output of that and
that makes sense because you can view
transformation matrices really as
functions functions
that map points on the coordinate plane
so in this situation what would be the
transformation matrix that is a
composition of these two
pause this video and think about that
all right well what would happen is we
would first transform
any point using these two vectors the 0
5 the 2 negative 1 because that's the
first transformation we do
and then we would apply this
transformation to
whatever the resulting vector is now
that seems pretty involved and we don't
want to write it in terms of a or b's we
just want to write it in terms of a
transformation matrix
so one way to think about it is we can
transform
each of these vectors that you have
in matrix a because remember that says
what do you turn the
the vectors 1 0 and 0 1 into so
if we transform 0 5 using
the matrix b and if we transform 2
negative 1
using the matrix b and we put them in
their respective columns
we should have the composition of this
so let me write it this way
create a little bit of space so let's
say that the composition
b of a is equal to
all right a big two by two matrix right
over here the first thing we can do is
apply
transformation matrix b to the purple
column right over here and what is that
going to tell us
well that's going to be 0 times negative
3
1. so let me write it that way it's
going to be
0 times negative 3
1 plus 5
times 0 4 0 4.
and this is going to give us a 2 by 1
vector right over here
so that can you can v view as filling up
the first column
of this transformation this composition
i guess you could say
and then let's think about this second
vector right over here 2 negative 1.
if you transform that using b what are
you going to get you're going to get 2
times negative 3 1. so i'll write it
here 2
times negative 3 1
plus negative 1 or maybe i just write it
this way minus
1 times
0 4. and this doesn't look
like a matrix just yet but if you work
through it it will become
a matrix for example if i multiply well
0 times all of this is going to be 0
and then 5 times 0 is going to be let me
just write it this way
this would turn into 5 times 0 is 0 5
times 4
is 20. and then this matrix
right over here is going to be 2 times
negative 3 1 is going to be negative
6 2 and then we have minus
0 4 and now if we wanted to write this
clearly as a 2 by 2 matrix
this would be equal to and we get a
little bit of a drum roll here
the first column is 0 20
and then the second column is going to
be let's see negative 6
minus 0 is still negative 6 and 2 minus
4
is negative 2 and we're done we have
just created a
new transformation matrix that's based
on the composition
b of a so if you apply transformation a
first
to any vector and then apply
transformation b
to whatever you get there that is
equivalent
to just applying this one 2 by 2
transformation matrix b
of a